[تصفيق]
تطلع ان شاء الله
الاستمرار التواصل والتنسيق مع معالي
الوزير ايضا فتح قنوات التواصل فيما بين
الاجهزه الحكوميه
واستمرار عملنا بشكل سفيف حتى نصل الى ما
تطلع اليه سويا من
استعاده هذه العلاقه الهامه
اكتشفت مصادر العربيه انه خلال زياره وزير
الخارجيه التركي القاهره تم الاتفاق على
عقد قمه بين السيسي واردوغان في النصف
الثاني من العام الحالي كما طالبت تركيا
مصر بضروره وجود تفاهمات في ملفي ترسيم
الحدود والغاز بالاضافه الى انضمام الاخير
الى منتدى غاز شرق المتوسط فيما اشارت
المصادر نفسها الى ان مصر طالبت تركيا
بدعم سياده ليبيا واجراء الانتخابات ورحبت
انقره بذلك
يعني هي نقطه تحول مهمه طبعا ردا على
زيارته
الى تركيا للمواساه في
الماساه التي حدثت بعد الزجال ولكن ايضا
تاتي في وسط تغيرات خطيره في الموقف
الاقليمي والموقف العالمي والظروف العالمي
هناك حاجه مشتركه من الواضح يقال من قبل
البلدين للاخر بمعنى ان دخول مصر في
المعدله السوريه مهمه بالنسبه للجانب
التركي ايضا الدخول مصر في موضوع شرق
المتوسط والحاق تركيا بما تم في المنتدى
الغاز والمنظمه الاقليميه ايضا مهم
فبالتالي في احتياجات مشتركه في هذا
الاطار